[Music]
many of us are stuck at home during this
crisis or are we stuck are we enjoying
time with the family or as my favorite
son said to me use it as a time of
self-reflection mom I don't know about
that but whatever you're doing chances
are you might be watching shows like
HBO's Westworld Tandy Newton won an Emmy
Award for her performance in the sci-fi
series
she plays Maeve a self-aware robot who
fights for her freedom last season the
androids revolted at Westworld a theme
park where humans could live out their
wildest fantasies and let me tell you
some of these fantasies are wild on this
Sunday's episode Mavis sent on a mission
in a new world
Hanako Gordon on yet their internal
botany
annachi Gary tossed a grenade well
you're very pretty on you
you're a bit old meet something that
aims for you and Tandy Newton there she
is joins us from her home in London -
Lee Newton it's so good to see you I'm
so glad well I feel the same about you
well Bart to you welcome welcome welcome
to you yes we are
I watched his show Tandy and sometimes
honest to god I don't know what I'm
watching it's a dark Odyssey sometimes
it's artificial intelligence sometimes
it's a real world sometimes it not it's
not sometimes death doesn't always mean
dead I mean it just takes us on such a
wild ride so I'm wondering for you when
you get the scripts are you looking at
it thinking what's gonna happen next -
it's definitely mind expanding and it
has been from the very beginning that's
what I love about it and it is fantasy
but it hinges on the fact that this is
50 60 years in the future
and it's anyone's guess as to what is
likely you know that the show is
projecting and you know what we're
experiencing now I mean even Westworld
didn't haven't used this as a storyline
then you feel it come rave I know really
great serie it's pretty grave but but I
mean I feel like okay I'm finding it
hard - I'm finding it hard to watch
stuff that isn't to read a novel or to
watch fiction I just I'm just consuming
real news whether it's documentaries
whether it's I just need information I
know a lot of people out there are
feeling the same you know so something
like Westworld these are out of balance
between you know what's real and and
what could be so I find it strangely
compelling at this time to watch wess
world
I know the world is really upside down
and for a lot of people West world is an
escape for people you know Maeve uses
her her intelligence as a superpower
what do you expect what can we expect on
her this season because she's part robot
and then it's Dolores versus Maebh I'm
on Team Maeve but it what do you what
thinking I'm going to the new season yes
I am I am what I love about made the
season is that she has no loyalty to any
side so it makes her a very strong it
makes her neutral her neutrality I think
is really important and from that place
I think it's it's better for an audience
to really judge how they feel because
she's not on any one side so I think
that's that's a huge strength for for
the character this season and I loved it
I loved it
well what I like is you get to do so
many different things with her and she
and also Tandy she's very pretty
Anthony loved the painting behind you I
wanted to say I love the painting behind
you and we loved seeing everybody's
homes but anyway I wanted to say that
yeah really gorgeous but maybe your
character may have has become a real fan
favorite why do you think Maeve has
resonated so much oh because she like so
many of us she has become aware of
betrayal has become aware of who's
pulling her strings and how that
betrayal once she's aware of it she just
Rises like a phoenix and I think a lot
of people identify with that you know
that what would they do if they knew the
truth and she does what what what most
of us wish we could do she's not someone
who leaves a room and says oh god I wish
I'd said that she says it in the moment
you know she it's it's very compelling I
mean she's a what a brilliant character
I get to say those words and be in those
situations I mean particularly episode 2
this season was just ah I relished every
second as she is updating herself and
learning but I think that you know yeah
she's a she's a robot but in life that's
what we do with with the truth it sets
us free and some yeah it's great to have
a character who grows Tony
well Teddy you've got all these powerful
hey how are you good morning
so you know I've got a question that I
really wish we're no longer even a
question in our universe I mean I pined
for the day when this is no longer
relevant but Tuesday was equal pay day
for men and women you've got this set
full of powerful ladies and now you guys
are getting the same salary as your male
co-stars just what did that mean yeah
for you and for the show it was surreal
because I had a naive was I to think
that we were already on equal pay I just
assumed that you know I'm doing my thing
I'm acting I'm my other activities you
know human rights work I just it's like
I haven't realized that that was still
an issue
so when HBO on the back of times ups
times up you know worked hard to raise
awareness about the lack of equality
between men and women in the in in in in
the area of wages and when they came to
us with the figure it was bittersweet
because on the one hand it was this
giant hike to a new figure and on the
other hand it may be very reason it was
such a giant John Paul II I apologize
such a high Tandi I apologize I've got
to jump in you get to say I apologize
I've got to jump in here you're gonna
cut us off same token anyway I've just
getting here here for free Westworld
airs Sundays on HBO we'll be right back
sandy thank you